hit your door open again are you good
thank you for answering your text
messages funniest Pines a charm
you look great Thank You this is mamrie
Hart
she's not only one of my favorite
comedians but she's one of my best
friends and co-host of the series hey
USA she also has her first book you
deserve a drink coming out on May 26 and
I'm so happy she's here I'm literate yes
I'm a Marie because you're one of my
first guests and because you're one of
my best friends and because I assume
you're wildly hungover I heard yeah I
thought we wouldn't do anything too
exotic or challenging instead I thought
we'd do something that we normally do so
we're going to get drunk and adopt some
dolls close we are going to get you
situated is you're one of my favorite
comedians and best friends sit on the
floor but yeah no chairs are for the
people I don't know in real life okay
got it you got it
so sterile no today we're gonna be
playing a game called deal back out
graphic big time we're gonna go back and
forth showing each other some of the
dumbest videos we've been able to find
on the internet and the person that
cannot deal with it meaning that they
laugh is going to have to do something
awful take a shot oh my god I couldn't
possibly my parents DVR'd this what do
we drink today we're drinking some sort
of vodka solution that someone that's
enough honey okay great
awesome awesome well as a gracious host
and you being a guest in my house uh-huh
I'll go first
okay okay this is the first video for
using this table ready here we go ma'am
oh no you mark this woman is so much
trying to not fall how'd you like start
a default smoked a cigarette all she had
to do was draw like on the scooter just
let go of the scooter let that be a life
lesson to all of you drop the scooter
protect your cooter you laughed you've
to take a shot ski boots BAM
oh yeah we call them floor shots that's
where they come from and that's where I
end up yeah Cheers
hey girl I'm back baby to back ok memory
children 8 alright the next one I have
it's called Space Needle ok I know Oh No
ok great intro oh definitely the friend
you want to bring to like a 60-story
building yep that's the one who trip
trip flops
it was the dignitary turn that I think
the universe was like uh-uh no mech duh
ok memory this one is now for you and it
is aptly titled bikini fail uh is this
the other possible name for my biography
I mean others wouldn't go for it but
bikini fell the story of memory ok I
already love it cuz she looks like she's
sitting in a lazy boy recliner in the
middle of the damn woods okay and she's
got like a no one is open her is this
Russia this has gotta be Russia ah this
is Russia yeah she needed not to Russia
getting up whoa whoa sorry this last one
of deal is probably my favorite okay we
are huge dog fans here at Rice and
memory friendship yes and we love a pug
this one's called pug pool and I am
already all in okay look you Oh No
get ready oh oh it's kind of volleyball
otherwise I'll stuck it's curious
Oh Oh aah
I think this has taught me that the
greatest comedian of all time is gravity
Oh completely yeah Wow
mamrie you win for participating in the
first game of deal the deal crown so you
got a deal at Goodwill on a dirty pot
big time do I look like Johnny Appleseed
Joanne Appleseed
you look like flava flav cosplay I'll
take it really great Thank You mamrie
Hart everybody make sure you follow her
on all of our social media outlets and
this bid is done so memory you are done
play me out girl